Every year, Oxford Dictionary puts out a word of the year.
The word of the year for 2016 was this.
Post-Truth.
It's an adjective.
It's defined as relating to or denoting circumstances
in which objective facts are less influential in shaping public opinion
than appeals to emotion and personal belief.
So in other words, post-truth means that you don't really need to worry about objective facts
and it's really about how you feel about something.
You don't have to necessarily agree with objective truth.
But your own subjective truth is much more valuable.
Essentially, this is the word of the year.
This is exactly what we're up against or what our students are up against.
Every day that they walk into the classroom at school,
every day that they interact with their friends and they see media and movies and music
and everything else that's on TV, this is what we're talking about.
It's essentially relativism, the idea that objective truth no longer matters
and no longer has any space in our heads to navigate our own reality.
In other words, if I don't like objective reality, I can just completely ignore it
and not worry about it and create my own reality, my own truth.
You can probably already start to imagine what kind of problems this is going to cause in your own mind
against what students, which is also often why we as leaders will stand in front of our students
and start talking about something that we think and we know is objectively true,
especially what's based on Scripture.
And there's a wall between what we're saying and our students
because oftentimes they're looking at what we're saying and thinking,
well, wait a minute, that's what you think to be true.
I don't accept that as true.
Even though we're saying that this is objectively true, that this is absolutely true,
they don't necessarily agree with it.
See, you and I probably accepted truth for what it is, even if we didn't like it.
So, okay, this is what truth is, this is the reality of the situation
or the reality of our environment or the reality of our lives.
We may not like it, but we accept it and we deal with it or we change it or whatever.
Students will base their truth off of the reality that they create
because they're told that's exactly what you're allowed to do.
But it's important that you help your students see truth for what it really is.
This lesson is so, so important as you continue to move forward
because you can't talk about the reality or the authority of Scripture.
You can't talk about the reality of the resurrection.
You can't talk about the existence of God.
You can't talk about the problem of evil.
You can't talk about really anything else that you're going to dive into
until your students understand the nature of truth.
So, truth is what corresponds with reality.
When you think of truth, when you help your students think of truth,
sort of help them navigate away from this idea of post-truth
and remind them that truth is what is real, what is reality.
So, reality is really a thing that's independent of me or you or your students.
So, what it is regardless of we're interacting with it or not.
So, more than just understanding truth and reality
is the understanding that genuine freedom comes by living through truth.
Because remember, we're talking about what it means to have faith.
We're talking about truth in that context.
And our students want to be free.
We want them to experience the freedom that is in Christ
and that comes from understanding what truth is.
And truth is what corresponds with reality.
Now, it might be really attempting for them to think,
well, as long as it makes sense or as long as it's practical,
then that's fine.
Then it can be true, right?
It can be coherent.
It can be practical.
It can be whatever.
As long as it makes sense to me, then it can be true.
Well, that's not necessarily the case.
And if you think about it,
there's lots of things that are coherent.
Think about belief in things like Santa Claus or the Easter Bunny
fairy.
When we're kids, those things make all the sense in the world.
But we know that these things don't line up with reality.
And parents may spend a lot of time making these things incredibly practical.
But yet they don't line up with reality.
And so it might make sense for some other religious beliefs
or some other ideas that students may come across that sound good.
Sound like they make sense.
Sound very practical.
That doesn't mean they line up with reality.
You know, it might sound really nice to say all religions lead to the same place
or that all religions have some idea of truth to them.
But then what do we do in John 14 when Jesus says,
I am the way of the truth in the life.
Nobody gets the Father but by me.
Jesus is making an objective truth claim.
So either that is true or it's not.
And it doesn't matter what I think of it.
So either what Jesus said is true or not,
whether I interact with it or not,
whether I believe in it or not, it's either true or it's false.
That's what we call objective truth.
So if what Jesus is saying is true,
that makes every other belief that contradicts belief in Jesus to be false.
So we want our students to be able to see that truth is so critically important
to furthering our discussions on what it means to believe in Christianity.
So students in small group are going to have a really good chance this week
to discuss and explore how truth opens the door to a life of freedom.
Because really when we boil this down,
understanding truth is more than just intellectually understanding what truth is.
It's understanding it so that it leads them to freedom
that they can be in Christ and they can live the life that God has purposed for them.
So when we're thinking about truth, there's two kinds of truth that we're really talking about.
Now I've talked a lot about the idea of objective truth
but there's also something we call subjective truth.
So there's objective and subjective.
Well what's the difference?
And oftentimes this is where our view of truth gets sort of confused
because we mix these two up.
So helping to understand these on your end as well as helping your students to understand this
is going to be one of those things that's going to help take that wall
that's dividing you and your students down
to help them see exactly what it is that you're saying when you're talking about scripture.
So first let's talk about the idea of subjective truth.
Well what is the idea of subjective truth?
But if I say something like,
I love mint chocolate chip ice cream.
But you like another flavor, chocolate let's say.
Is it true that I think mint chocolate chip ice cream is the best kind of ice cream?
Well of course it's true because I think it.
And is it true at the same time that if you think chocolate ice cream is the best kind of ice cream
that that is in fact a true statement?
Well of course it's a true statement because you think it.
See these are subjective truth statements.
They're true because they're based on my experience and my experience only.
So it doesn't matter.
And two different things can be both equally true at the same time.
Two different flavors of ice cream can be both true at the exact same time
because it's completely subjective.
And if I'm not here to say it then this truth statement doesn't matter anymore.
So it's completely subjective.
On the other side is the idea of objective truth.
Now objective truth has to do with the object.
So if you think of it this way,
subject object.
Truth statement is about the subject here.
Truth statement is about the object here.
Okay?
So if I'm talking about ice cream I'm talking about how I feel about the ice cream.
But here if I'm talking about something like my shirt,
if I told you that my shirt was blue you tell me I'm wrong.
Well why?
Because my shirt isn't blue.
My shirt is green.
If I told my shirt is black or white or anything but the color that my shirt actually is
that I'm wrong.
It's completely independent of my opinion.
It's completely independent of my experience.
Even if I never bought the shirt and it's still on the rack at the store
the shirt is still the color that it is until it ceases to be that shirt and that color.
So it doesn't matter.
So it's based on the object, my shirt, not my opinion.
This is based on my opinion.
I'm the subject.
So that's kind of the distinguishing feature.
The problem is that what we do is we lump religion over here.
And we lump Jesus on the side of subjective truth.
And we say that well I can believe in Jesus subjectively because based on my experience
I think it's true and it doesn't matter what anybody else thinks.
And it doesn't matter if you disagree because ever somebody else can believe in something completely different
and it be equally true.
But now we go back to John 14.
Jesus said something that is independent of me.
He said something that is an objective truth statement whether it's true or not.
So that puts belief in Jesus on the objective side.
So when we're talking about Jesus, we're talking about Christianity,
we're talking about the way in which the world works and God being creator and all the things that we're going to talk about for the rest of the year
we're talking about objective truth statements.
They're either true or they're not.
And we have to make sure our students understand that they're here.
It's not a matter of opinion or experience.
It's a matter of reality.
So truth is what corresponds with reality which then leads to freedom.
This is what we want our students to see primarily this week is that understanding objective truth,
understanding that truth is often objective,
understanding that belief in Jesus is objective.
It is how it corresponds and lines up with reality.
And understanding those things is what's going to lead your students to the feeling
and the understanding and the experience of genuine freedom in Christ.